[Music]
you
all right so there is more we are
continuing here this is likely going
know people wondering if this is a new
this is an old stream this is live this
is 5:30 1 p.m. Eastern Time there is
more today with Laura Cooper and David
Hale and this is a long day this is a
long day we started this morning at 8:30
a.m. 8:30 a.m. this is about to continue
and my sense is that what we're going to
have to do because we do have live
coverage plan this evening of the
Democratic presidential debate at 9 p.m.
on twitch twitch TV slash David Pakman
so we are going to I guess we'll just be
here for a little while and my plan was
in two hours to do oh man my phone is
blowing up too because things are
getting completely crazy the plan was at
7:30 I'm sorry at 8:30 from 8:30 to 9:00
p.m. to do a half-hour pre-debate stream
on YouTube just to tell people we're
gonna be over on Twitch and then to
switch over on Twitch at 9:00 p.m.
Eastern my sense is this hearing may go
all the way till then although they've
said not to they say they are not going
to do the long question-and-answer
period I don't know if that means the 45
and 45 and they'll go right to 5-minute
questions I genuinely have no idea
the most notable hearing so far was
definitely Gordon Sunland who I mean he
just confirmed everything it's it is it
is truly stunning now what is this
little white bar down here I'm wondering
oh that's interesting there seems to be
something a little off see if I can fix
that because we didn't have that before
let's take a look here there we go I
think we took care of that relatively
quickly good so in any case yeah we this
is this is another one we will take
calls people asking yeah what we might
take calls later like after the
democratic debate I don't I mean it's
just a crazy day it's just a crazy day
we've been we've been streaming all day
and what's crazy is in addition if you
go to my web site you will see that at 3
p.m. the
time we published like today's broadcast
show which is you know like our our
broadcast show and the bonus show and
everything so it's been an absolutely
insane crazy day let me say thanks to a
few people who are signing up here
Michael Pritchard is a new member Zayn
costs Dillon Littlefield
Loreena Lew era Suzan Yulin Dorf and who
else ok I think everybody else has been
thanked on one stream or another it's
been crazy it's been crazy it's hard to
even keep up with everything that's
going on but I think this is important
stuff so I've committed to streaming all
of these we will be back tomorrow I am
not having any medical recreational or
conspiratorial amounts of espresso at
all
I am yeah you know people are saying
this is the first time they've been
notified about these streams I also just
got the email and I'm realizing this is
the only stream I've gotten an email for
myself very weird
Rachel Hooton says David I'm impressed
by your patience and dedication to
broadcast all the hearings thanks Rachel
I appreciate that
friendly guy says it just alerted me
you're live at five-thirty have you been
broadcasting all day we have NYX salmon
sends to $5 super chats and Obed
Pichardo sends a $5 super chat other
people saying they've received numerous
notifications who knows who knows what's
going on every every system is falling
apart that's what seems to be going on
yeah a lot of people saying this is the
only stream they've received by push
that's interesting because I don't see
anything it's like I can schedule it I
can enable or not enable DVR and ads are
on those are the only options I have so
I don't know yeah alright so in any case
we'll see it is possible that twitch
will shut down tonight's stream as we
get a look at gymnasium Jordan the
comb-over starting to be a little bit in
desperate disrepair
we we we may get shut down tonight by
MSNBC trying to stream over on Twitch I
don't know but I hope you'll follow us
there at twitch.tv slash David Pakman
that's starting around 9 p.m. Eastern
Time that's where we will be streaming
the debate for fear of for fear of
copyright issues but no issues here
because it is public domain House of
Representatives video the Pope Nick is
asking about the posters behind some of
the members of Congress it's mostly
propaganda stuff that's that's basically
it Kelly L hey David you're one of my
favorites so progressive Warren or
Bernie 2020 yes indeed Kelly yes indeed
there are free super chats available to
you if you're a youtube Premium Member
and you are on mobile I believe you have
to be on mobile if you click the dollar
sign reportedly everybody with YouTube
premium has free super chats you get $5
from YouTube and you can send it to
whoever you want that is an eligible
channel and we are an eligible Channel
so I would encourage you to do that
people asking if yesterday's video was a
copyright stricken it was and then I
immediately appealed it and then we got
it back I mean it's crazy it's like who
knows what the hell is going on it's
totally cuckoo
I only saw free super chats on mobile
they didn't pierre appear on desktop
yeah that seems to be it that seems to
be it people asking if I'm gay I am NOT
I am NOT but there's nothing wrong with
that if I were it would be a beautiful
thing and I would tell you
devyn newness on suicide watch some
people suggesting yeah Nunez did look
despondent earlier people checking in
from Hawaii Israel Finland there was
actually a crazy super chat battle
earlier we had a viewer from Sweden and
a viewer viewer from Norway fighting
each other with like a hundred dollar
super chat than 125 then 150 then 255
social democracy seems to be working
very
very well in Sweden and Norway because
there were super chats raining in it was
crazy people asking if I believe Eric
SWA well did release flatulence during
the infamous viral video I believe that
he did I believe that he did and maybe
we can even look at the video before we
start here he denies it he denies it
but oh it's really now that it's like
the videos everywhere and now that I'm
actually looking for one it's very
difficult to find it let me see here I
think we have time I believe that that
is what it was and you know it's it's
anyone's guess but it was quite a quite
a moment let me see over here I think
I've got the video let's just quickly
take a look at this before things get
started so far the evidence is
uncontradicted that the president used
taxpayer dollars to ask the Ukrainians
to help him cheat it almost seems fake
it almost seems fake but he does flinch
in a certain way well just one more time
and then we're done with it's like his
the pause in his speech seems too
coincidental way way way too
coincidental to have been nothing to
have been nothing it's weird
$50 super chat from underscore - double
underscore - underscore how will
Republicans try to discredit these
witnesses boredom these it's been a very
long day already the only thing that's
gonna happen here is that witnesses are
going to be bored and you know soon
things are going into we're past the 5
o'clock news on the East Coast we're
going beyond we're gonna start getting
into the time where people will be ready
for the 9 p.m. presidential debate so I
think that the idea is just to just
boredom and that's it the key issue will
be the David Hale testimony about the
phone call that he overheard that will
basically be it this weird guy says
sunland looks kind of like Jeff Ross
except he was getting roasted instead of
doing the roasting that's it's
interesting serious thought says I've
been watching you since my first
semester in college now getting my
master's one of the few voices of reason
and truth
awesome bro thank you I appreciate that
a lot of people checking in with free
super chats mr3 3m are we starting
looks like soon I'll thank people until
they start Kenneth Erickson Tina Sergio
Thank You Tina very much I appreciate
that who else do we have
Phil M says that it was not flatulence
from Erik's wall well it was a cup
moving across the desk / MSNBC yeah
that's what they're saying I mean it's
just you know do we believe that I'm not
really sure committee will come to order
all right here we go good afternoon
everyone this is the sixth in a series
of public hearings the committee will be
holding as part of the House of
Representatives impeachment inquiry
without objection the chair is
authorized to declare recess of the
committee at any time there is a quorum
present we will proceed today in the
same fashion as our other hearings I'll
make an opening statement then the
ranking member mr. Nunez will have an
opportunity to make a statement and we
will turn to our witnesses for the their
opening statements if they should choose
to make one for audience members we
welcome you and respect your interest in
being here in turn we ask for your
respect as we proceed with this hearing
as chairman I'll make any necessary or
take any necessary appropriate steps to
maintain order and ensure that the
committee is run in accordance with
House Rules in House Resolution 661 out
to give an opening statement in the
impeachment inquiry into Donald J Trump
the 45th President of the United States
this afternoon the American people will
hear from two witnesses who are both
veteran national security professionals
one at the Department of State and the
other at the Defense Department David
Hale is the Undersecretary of State for
political affairs the third most senior
official in the Department and the most
senior foreign service officer Laura
Cooper serves as deputy assistant
secretary of defense for Russia Ukraine
Eurasia and is responsible for a broad
range of countries in the former Soviet
Union and the Balkans between them they
have several decades of national
security experience serving both
Republican and Democratic presidents and
as we have heard from other dedicated
public servants
like former ambassador to Ukraine Marie
Ivanovitch former Deputy Assistant
Secretary of State George Kent
ambassador Bill Taylor lieutenant
colonel Alexander VIN Minh and Jennifer
Williams their only priority has been
the security of the United States under
secretary Hale was witnessed to the
smear campaign against the ambassador to
Ukraine Marie Ivanovitch and the efforts
by some in the State Department to help
her in late March the Ivanovich reached
out to Hale for assistance telling him
in an email that the tempo of social
media and other criticisms of her were
such that she felt she could no longer
function unless there was a strong
statement of defense of her from the
State Department helped push to get the
State Department to put out a robust
full-page statement of defense and
praise from Vassily Ivanovich sadly to
no avail
that silence continues to today in late
April we heard in riveting testimony
last Friday from bastard Ivanovich she
was recalled to Washington and informed
that she had lost the confidence of the
President the Secretary of State did not
meet with her his subordinates dealt
with her instead with the departure of
Ivanovitch Hale watched as three new
players moved in to assume a prominent
role in trump's ukraine policy the three
amigos were nominally led by Energy
Secretary Rick Perry but it would be
ambassador Volcker and ambassador
Solomon presumably working with
ambassador Taylor it would be the ones
really doing the continual work here in
mid-summer Trump ordered a suspension of
military aid to Ukraine despite the fact
that the aid had been authorized and
appropriated by Congress and that the
Defense Department in consultation with
the State Department had certified
Ukraine met all the necessary
requirements to receive the aid
including anti-corruption reform the aid
was in the national interests of the
United States and critical to Ukraine's
security a country that had been invaded
by Russia from her office in the
Pentagon miss Cooper oversaw a
significant amount of security
assistance flowing to Ukraine and was
involved in efforts to understand and
reverse the suspension of nearly 400
million in US aid Cooper along
others learned about the freeze during a
series of interagency meetings in the
last two weeks of July at the first
meeting on July 18th and OMB represented
a relayed that quote the White House
chief of staff has conveyed that the
president has concerns about Ukraine and
Ukraine's security assistance unquote
and that a hold had been ordered by the
president no explanation was provided
all of the agencies responsible for
Ukraine policy supported security
assistance and advocated for lifting of
the hold the only dissenting voice was
the Office of Management and Budget
which was following the orders of
President Trump and still no good
explanation of the hold was provided
while the eight suspension had not been
made public word was getting out
Catherine Croft special advisor for
Ukraine negotiation work closely with
ambassador Volcker and who testified
before this committee at a deposition
received two separate calls in July or
August from officials at the Ukrainian
embassy who quote approached me quietly
and in confidence to ask me about an OMB
hold on Ukraine security assistance
Kroft was quote very surprised at the
effectiveness of my Ukrainian
counterparts diplomatic tradecraft as in
to say they found out very early on much
earlier than I expected them to the
Ukrainians wanted answers but Croft did
not have a good response but then in
late August Cooper met with kurt volker
with whom she had met many times in the
past during that meeting in which they
were discussing the hold on security
assistance Volcker revealed that he was
engaged in an effort to have the
government of Ukraine issue a statement
that would quote commit to the
prosecution of any individuals involved
in election interference unquote Cooper
understood that a Volkers effort were
successful the hold might be lifted
unbeknownst to Cooper no such statement
was forthcoming but the aid was abruptly
restored on September 11th days after
the three committees launched an
investigation into the Trump Ukraine
scheme and with that I now recognize the
ranking member
thank you as Swee Republicans have
argued at these hearings the American
people are getting a skewed impression
of these events that's because the
Democrats assumed full authority to call
witnesses and they promptly rejected any
new witnesses the Republicans requested
so I'd like to take a moment to discuss
a few of the people whose testimony has
been deemed unacceptable for the
American people to hear the
whistleblower the whistleblower is the
key figure who started this entire
impeachment charade by submitting a
complaint against President Trump that
relied on second-hand and third-hand
information and media reports
this began a bizarre series of events
although the complaint had no
intelligence component whatsoever the
intelligence community Inspector General
accepted it and even changed the
guidance on the complaint forms to
eliminate the requirement for first-hand
information then his office back dated
the forms to make them appear as if they
were published a month before Democrats
then took the extremely rare step of
pushing a whistleblower complaint into
the public using it as the centerpiece
of their impeachment crusade we later
learned the Democratic staff had prior
coordination with the whistleblower
though the Democrats themselves had
denied it on national television
following that revelation Democrats did
a dramatic about-face they suddenly
dropped their insistence that the
whistleblower testify to us and rejected
our request to hear from him then in a
hearing yesterday the Democrats cut off
our questions and accused us of trying
to out the whistleblower even though
they claim they don't even know who he
is
Alexander chalupa chalupas a former
operative for the Democratic National
Committee who worked with officials of
the Ukrainian embassy in Washington DC
in order to smear the Trump campaign in
2016
she met directly about these matters
with VIN Ukrainian and
chale who himself wrote an article
criticizing Trump during the 2016
campaign chalupas activities were one of
several indicators of Ukrainian election
meddling in 2016 all of which were aimed
at the Trump campaign once you
understand that Ukrainian officials were
cooperating directly with President
Trump's political opponents to undermine
his candidacy it's easy to understand
why the president would want to learn
the full truth about these operations
and why he would be skeptical of Ukraine
hunter Biden Biden is another witness
who the Democrats are sparing from
cross-examination is securing of an
extremely well-paying job on the board
of a corrupt Ukrainian company buri SEMA
highlights the precise corruption
problem in Ukraine concerned not only
president Trump but all of the witnesses
we've interviewed so far the Democrats
have dismissed questions about Biden's
role at burry smih as conspiracy
theories yet they're trying to impeach
president Trump for having expressed
concerns about the company if we could
hear from Biden we could ask him how he
got his position what did he do to earn
his lavish salary and what light could
he shed on corruption at this notorious
company but Biden would make an
inconvenient witness for the Democrats
and so they've blocked his testimony at
these hearings we've heard a lot of
secondhand third-hand information and
speculation about president Trump's
intentions but in the end the only
direct order we've heard from the
president is his order to our last
witness ambassador Sandlin
that he wanted nothing from Ukraine that
is at is consistent with the testimony
provided by Senator Johnson who said
that President Trump angrily denied
accounts that a quid pro quo existed
aside from rejecting our witnesses the
Democrats have tried other petty tricks
to shape public opinion just this
morning
they call the break in the hearing in
order to press their absurd arguments
two TV cameras then for this hearing
they cancelled the multiple rounds of
initial questioning they had earlier
today with ambassador Sunland and as
they have had with all the previous
witnesses who they bizarrely consider as
their star witnesses when you look
through the presumptions assumptions and
smoke-and-mirrors you see the facts of
this case are clear president Trump was
skeptical of foreign aid generally an
especially skeptical of aid to corrupt
countries like Ukraine he wanted to
discover the facts about Ukrainian
meddling in the 2016 election against
his campaign a brief hold on Ukrainian
aid was lifted without Ukraine taking
any steps they were supposedly being
bribed to do president szalinski
repeatedly said there was nothing
improper about President Trump's call
with him and he did not even know about
the holdin aid at the time he was
supposedly being extorted with it so
what exactly are the Democrats
impeaching the president for none of us
here really know because the accusations
change by the hour
once again this is impeachment in search
of a crime so chairman I would urge you
to bring this to a close sojourn this
hearing and move on and get back to the
work of the Intelligence Committee that
I yield back I thank the gentleman today
we are joined by ambassador David Hale
and miss Laura Cooper David Hale serves
as the Undersecretary of State for
political affairs for the Department of
State a position he has held since
August 30 2018 mr. Hale joined the
Foreign Service in 1984 and holds the
rank of career ambassador he previously
served as the ambassador to Pakistan
ambassador to Lebanon special envoy for
Middle East peace deputy special envoy
and ambassador to Jordan ambassador Hale
also served as Deputy Assistant
Secretary of State an executive
assistant to Secretary of State Albright
or Cooper is the deputy assistant
secretary of defense for Russia
Ukraine and Eurasia at the Department of
Defense she is a career member of the
senior executive service
miss Cooper previously served as a
principal director in the office of the
Assistant Secretary of Defense for
homeland defense and global security
affairs prior to joining the department
defense in 2001 miss Cooper was a policy
planning officer of the State Department
in the office of coordinator of
counterterrorism to final ports points
before witnesses are sworn first witness
depositions as part of this inquiry were
unclassified in nature and all open
hearings will also be held at the
unclassified level any information that
may touch on classified information will
be addressed separately and second
Congress will not tolerate any reprisal
threat of reprisal or attempt to
retaliate against any US government
official for testifying before Congress
including you or any of your colleagues
if you would both please rise and raise
your right hand I'll begin by swearing
you in do you swear or affirm that the
testimony you are about to give is the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth so help you God let the record
show the witness is answered in the
affirmative thank you and please be
seated the microphone is sensitive so
please speak directly into it
without objection your written
statements so it will be made part of
the record with that ambassador Hale if
you have an opening statement you're
free to give that and immediately
thereafter miss Cooper you are
recognized for your opening statement
mr. Chairman I I don't have a prepared
opening statement but I would like to
just comment of course as you said I've
been under secretary since August of
2018 a foreign service officer for over
35 years an ambassador three times
serving both Republican and Democratic
administrations proudly and I'm here in
response to your subpoena to answer the
questions of the committee Thank You
undersecretary miss Cooper mr. chairman
ranking member members of this committee
I appear today to provide facts and
answer questions based on my experience
as the Deputy Assistant Secretary of
Defense for Russia Ukraine and Eurasia I
would first like to describe my
background as well as my role and
each point relevant to your inquiry I
bring to my daily work into this
proceeding my sense of duty to u.s.
national security not to any political
party I proudly served to Democratic and
to Republican presidents I entered
government service through the
presidential management internship
competition joining the State Department
in 1999 to work on counterterrorism in
Europe and the former Soviet Union
inspired by working with the US military
on a Department of Defense rotational
assignment I decided to accept a civil
service position in the policy
organization of the office of the
Secretary of Defense in January 2001
where I have remained for the past 18
years
my strong sense of pride in serving my
country and dedication to my Pentagon
colleagues were cemented in the moments
after I felt the Pentagon shake beneath
me on September 11th 2001 my office was
scheduled to move into the section of
the Pentagon that was destroyed in the
attack but a construction delay meant
that we were still at our old desks in
the adjacent section on that devastating
day after we had wiped the black dust
from our desks and tried to get back to
work I found meaning by volunteering to
work on Afghanistan policy and would
give my next four years to this mission
I later had the opportunity to move into
the leadership ranks of my organization
and have had the privilege to manage
issues ranging from defense strategic
planning to homeland defense and mission
assurance I accepted the position of
principle director for Russia Ukraine
and Eurasia in 2016 and was honored to
be appointed formally to the position of
Deputy Assistant Secretary of Defense in
2018 in my current role I work to
advance u.s. national security with a
focus on deterring Russian aggression
and building strong partnerships with
the frontline states of Ukraine and
Georgia as well as ten other allies and
partners from the Balkans to the
Caucasus strengthening Ukraine's
capacity to defend itself against
Russian aggression is
central to my team's mission the United
States and our allies provide Ukraine
with us with security assistance because
it is in our national security interest
to deter Russian aggression around the
world we also provide security
assistance so that Ukraine can negotiate
a peace with Russia from a position of
strength the human toll continues to
climb in this ongoing war with 14,000
Ukrainian lives lost since Russia's 2014
invasion these sacrifices are
continually in my mind as I lead DoD
efforts to provide vital training and
equipment including defensive lethal
assistance to the Ukrainian armed forces
I have also supported a robust Ukrainian
Ministry of Defense program of defence
reform to ensure the long-term
sustainability of us investments and the
transformation of the Ukrainian military
from a Soviet model to a NATO
interoperable force the National Defense
Authorization Act requires the
Department of Defense to certify defence
reform progress to release half of the
Ukraine security assistance initiative
or USA I funds a provision we find very
helpful based on recommendations from me
and other key DoD advisors the
Department of Defense in coordination
with the Department of State certified
in may twenty nineteen that Ukraine had
quote taken substantial actions to make
defence institutional reforms for the
purposes of decreasing corruption
increasing accountability and sustaining
improvements of combat capability
unquote meriting obligation of the
entire 250 million in u.s. AI funds this
brings me to the topic of today's
proceedings
I would like to recap my recollection of
the timeline in which these events
played out I testified about all of this
at length in my deposition in July I
became aware of a hold being placed on
obligation of the State Department's
foreign military financing or FMF and
DoD's USA I funds
in a series of interagency meetings I
heard that the president had directed
the Office of Management and Budget to
hold the funds because of his concerns
about corruption in Ukraine let me say
at the outset that I have never
discussed this or any other matter with
the president and never heard directly
from him about this matter at a senior
level meeting I attended on July 26
chaired by national security council
leadership as at all other interagency
meetings on this topic of which I was
aware the national security community
expressed unanimous support for resuming
the funding as in the US national
security interest at the July 26th
meeting there was also a discussion of
how Ukrainian anti-corruption efforts
were making progress
DoD reiterated what we had said in our
earlier certification to Congress
stating that sufficient progress in
defense reform including anti-corruption
had occurred to justify the u.s. AI
spending I and others at the interagency
meetings felt that the matter was
particularly urgent because it takes
time to obligate that amount of money
and my understanding was that the money
was legally required to be obligated by
September 30th the end of the fiscal
year in the ensuing weeks until the hold
was released on September 11th I pursued
three tracks first starting on July 31st
and an interagency meeting I made clear
to the interagency leadership my
understanding that once DoD reaches the
point at which it does not have
sufficient time to obligate all the
funding by the end of the fiscal year
there were only two ways to discontinue
obligation of USA I a president directed
rescission or a DoD directed
reprogramming action either of which
would need to be notified to Congress I
never heard that either was being
pursued second I was in communication
with the DoD security assistance
implementing community to try to
understand exactly when they would reach
the point at which they would be unable
to obligate all the funds by the
and of the fiscal year I received a
series of updates and in a September 5th
update I and other senior Defense
Department leaders were informed that
over a hundred million could not be
obligated by September 30th and third I
was advocating for a meeting of the
cabinet level principals with the
president to explain why the assistance
should go forward although I heard of
attempts to discuss the issue with the
president I never received details about
any conversations other than a status
update that the hold had not been lifted
after the decision to release the funds
on September 11th of this year my
colleagues across the DoD security
assistance Enterprise worked tirelessly
to be able to ultimately obligate about
86% of the funding by the end of the
fiscal year more than they had
originally estimated they would be able
to due to a provision in September's
continuing resolution appropriating an
amount equal to the unobligated funds
from fiscal year 2019 we ultimately will
be able to obligate all of the u.s. AI
funds given how critical these funds are
for bolstering Ukraine's security and
deterring Russia
I appreciate this congressional action
that concludes my opening statement but
before answering your questions there is
one other matter I would like to address
I testified in a deposition before this
committee and other committees on
October 23rd 2019 at that time I was
asked questions about what I knew about
when the Ukrainian government may have
learned about any hold on security
assistance funds I answered those
questions based on my knowledge at that
time since my deposition I have again
reviewed my calendar and the only
meeting where I recall a Ukrainian
official raising the issue with me is on
September 5th at the Ukrainian
Independence Day celebration
I have however since learned some
additional information about this
subject from my staff prior to my
deposition testimony I avoided
discussing my testimony with members of
my
staff or anyone other than my attorney
to ensure that my deposition testimony
was based only on my personal knowledge
my deposition testimony was publicly
released on November 11th 2019 members
of my staff read the testimony and have
come to me since then and provided
additional information specifically on
the issue of Ukraine's knowledge of the
hold or of Ukraine asking questions
about possible issues with the flow of
assistance my staff showed me two
unclassified emails that they received
from the State Department one was
received on July 25th at 2:31 p.m. that
email said that the Ukrainian embassy
and House Foreign Affairs Committee are
asking about security assistance the
second email was received on July 25th
at 4:25 p.m. that email said that the
hill knows about the FMF situation to an
extent and so does the Ukrainian embassy
I did not receive either of these emails
my staff does not recall informing me
about them and I do not recall being
made aware of their content at the time
I do not have any additional information
about precisely what the Ukrainians may
have said what may have been their
source of information about a hold or
any possible issues with the flow of
assistance or what the State Department
officials may have told them my staff
also advised me in the last few days of
the following additional fact that may
be relevant to this inquiry again my
staff does not recall informing me about
them and I do not recall being made
aware of this on July 3rd at 4:23 p.m.
they received an email from the State
Department stating that they had heard
that the CN is currently being blocked
by OMB this apparently refers to the
congressional notifications state would
send for Ukraine FMF I have no further
information on this on July 25th a
member of my staff got a question from a
Ukraine embassy contact asking what was
going on with Ukraine's security
assistance because at that time we did
not know what the guidance was on USA I
the OMB notice of apportionment or
arrived that day but this staff member
did not find out about it until later I
was informed that the staff member told
the Ukrainian official that we were
moving forward on USA I but recommended
that the Ukraine embassy check in with
state regarding the FMF sometime during
the week of August 6 to 10 a Ukraine
embassy officer told a member of my
staff that a Ukrainian official might
raise concerns about security assistance
in an upcoming meeting my understanding
is that the issue was not in fact raised
again I have no further information
about what concerns about the security
assistance Ukraine may have had at that
time my staff also recall thinking that
Ukrainians were aware of the hold on
security assistance during August but
they cannot pinpoint any specific
conversations where it came up my staff
told me they are aware of additional
meetings where they saw officials from
the Ukrainian Embassy in August and they
believe that the question of the hold
came up at some point but they told me
they did not find any corresponding
email or other records of those meetings
consequently neither they nor I know
precisely when or what additional
discussions may have occurred with the
Ukrainians in the month of August if I
had more details on these matters I
would offer them to the committee but
this is the extent of additional
information I have received since my
deposition mr. chairman I welcome your
questions I will answer them to the best
of my ability thank you thank you for
your testimony for this hearing we will
forego the first round of questions by
committee counsel and immediately
proceed to member questions under the
five-minute rule I do want to respond to
the comments of my ranking member
however that I think suggested that this
was a surprise to the minority we
informed the minority last night after
our hearing that we would because of the
nature of the testimony today we did not
believe that a staff member round was
necessary and the message we got back
from the minority was okay got it
thanks for the heads-up so the minority
was on notice it raised no objection
about
going directly to member rounds I also
want to point out that the majority has
represented that we have not called any
minority witnesses that is not accurate
mr. Hale appears tonight as a minority
witness no that's not how you
characterize yourself mr. Hill but your
testimony was requested by the minority
likewise two of the witnesses yesterday
pastor Volker as well as mr. Morrison
were both minority requested witnesses
now mr. Volker pastor Volker testified
that he didn't believe any of the
allegations against Joe Biden and in
retrospect that he should have
understood that an investigation into
BER yzma was really an investigation
into Biden which he acknowledged would
be inappropriate and mr. Morrison gave
testimony as to conversations that he
had with ambassador Sandman about the
conversations that he had relayed to the
Ukrainians about the hold and security
assistance being a result of the failure
to secure the investigation so I can
understand why the minority does not
want to now characterize them as
minority requested witnesses but
nonetheless they were minority requested
witnesses I now recognize myself for
five minutes and I want to begin by
asking you
miss Cooper about what you just informed
us of to make sure that I understand the
import of what you're saying as early as
July 25th the same day revered president
szalinski on the phone and asked for
this favor the same day that president
Solinsky thank the United States for its
military support and signaled it was
ready to purchase more javelins on that
date you got inquiries your staff got
inquiries from someone at the Ukrainian
embassy who was concerned about the
status of the military assistance is
that correct sir that's correct
I would say that specifically the
Ukrainian embassy staff asked what is
going on with Ukrainian security
assistance and did that connote
you that they were concerned that
something was in fact going on with it
yes sir
and you received I guess your staff
received more than one inquiry on that
date what was the other the nature of
the other inquiry on July 25th sir the
that was the one inquiry to my staff but
the other points that I had raised were
emails reflecting outreach to the State
Department so the Ukrainian Embassy was
also constant contacting the State
Department to find out about its portion
of military assistance yes sir
and was that similarly a concern about
what's going on with our military aid it
was similarly a question about what
what's going on with the Security
Assistance and your staff or one of the
other department staff also heard in
August additional inquiries from the
Ukrainian embassy about a potential
holdup in the military assistance sir I
want to be careful about how I phrase
this my staff recall having had meetings
with Ukrainian embassy representatives
during the month of August and they
believed that the topic came up at some
point during those meetings but they
don't recall the precise date or
specifically what the the nature of the
discussion was but your staff at least
gleaned from those conversations that
Ukrainian embassy was aware that there
was some kind of a hold on the
assistance so the way I would phrase it
is that there was some kind of an issue
yes you were now as group of the third
witness before our committee who has
testified that the crane Ian's found out
about the problem or hold on the
security assistance prior to it becoming
public but you're the first to indicate
that that may go back as early as the
date of the president's call the
president Solinsky let me move to a
related issue in August you testified at
your deposition that you met with kurt
volker i believe was in august 20th the
hold on security
was still in place you testified that
ambassador Volker told you that if he
could get Solinsky to make a public
statement quote that would somehow
disavow any interference in US elections
and would commit to the prosecution of
any individuals involved in election
interference it might lift the hold on
security assistance is that correct sir
I believe that I testified that it was
my inference that that would lift the
hold on Ukraine's security assistance
and that was your inference because at
the time you were talking about the hold
on security assistance that's correct
the first part of our conversation was
about the hold on security assistance
and it was during that portion of the
conversation that he brought up the
effort to get this public statement it
was during that conversation I'm not
sure I would say it's during that part
of the conversation what else did you
discuss in the conversation the only two
topics that I recall are the urgency of
lifting the hold on security assistance
and then him relaying this separate
diplomatic effort that I had previously
been unaware of so you don't have any
discussion about any white house meeting
sir I don't recall specifically talking
about the White House meeting but we
I've had many conversations about the
desire for the White House meeting so
it's likely that that was a part of the
conversation but the two things you do
recall or you talked about the hold on
security assistance and that he brought
up this public statement that they
wanted Solinsky to get that he thought
might be useful that is correct sir mr.
Nunez mr. Ratcliffe thank the gentleman
for yielding
ambassador Hale miss Cooper thank you
both for being here in his opening
ranking member Nunez reference president
Trump's general skepticism of providing
aid and the amount of foreign aid being
provided to foreign
trees would you agree with that
characterization ambassador hell we've
all often heard at the State Department
that the president United States wants
to make sure that foreign assistance is
reviewed scrupulously to make sure that
it's in truly in US national interests
and that we evaluated continuously so
that it meets certain criteria that the
president's established and since his
election is a fair to say that President
Trump has looked to overhaul how foreign
aid is distributed yes the NSC launched
a foreign assistance review process
sometime I think it was late August or
early September 2018 all right and
throughout both his campaign in his
administration President Trump has
repeatedly sought to reframe reframe
American foreign policy in economic
terms and as he described America first
policy and consistent with that well
before there was a whistleblower talking
about a pause on aid to the Ukraine the
president had expressed genuine concern
about providing us foreign assistance to
that point is it fair to say the
president has wanted to ensure the
American taxpayer money was being
effectively and efficiently spent
outside of the United States yes that is
the broad intent of the foreign
assistance review among other goals and
has the president expressed that he
expects our allies to give their fair
share of foreign aid as evidenced by a
point that he raised during the July
25th phone call with President Solinsky
to that effect the principle of greater
burden sharing by allies and other
like-minded states is an important
element of the foreign assistance review
is it fair to say that in the Trump
administration US aid is withheld from
foreign countries for a number of
factors correct and you've testified
your prior testimony that it is normal
to have delays on aid I may have said it
that way but it is certainly an
occurrence it does occur in the past
year Ukraine was not the only country to
have aid with held from it is that
correct correct in the past year was aid
held withheld from Pakistan yes sir
why was aid withheld from Pakistan
because of unhappiness over the policies
and behavior of the Pakistani government
toward certain proxy groups
that were involved in conflicts of the
United States and in the past year was
eight also withheld from Honduras aid
was withheld from the three states in
central northern Central America yes the
past year was aid withheld from Lebanon
yes sir
and when Aid was first held withheld
from Evan ah from Lebanon were you given
a reason why it was withheld no so
having no explanation for why aid is
being withheld is not uncommon I would
say it is not the normal way that we
function but does happen it does happen
and is it true that when Aid was being
withheld from Lebanon that was at the
same time the aid was being withheld
from Ukraine correct sir and you've
testified that the aid to Lebanon still
hasn't been released is that right that
is correct all right
but the aid to Ukraine was released on
September 11th correct
I read that yes so it's fair to say that
Aid has been withheld from several
countries across the globe for various
reasons and in some cases for reasons
that are still unknown just in the past
year correct sir
so assertions been made that president
Trump's Ukraine policy changed when
there was a pause in the the aid or the
aid was withheld is that an accurate
statement that was not the way I
understood things to be happening at the
time we were not given an explanation
and in terms of our policy in terms of
aid to Ukraine you've described it as
very robust our aid to Ukraine yes yes
as evidenced by president Trump's policy
decision to provide lethal defensive
weapons javelin missiles it was very
robust yes sir and that was a decision
the president Trump made that President
the prior administration President Obama
had not done lethal weapons had not been
provided to the Ukraine in the Obama
administration correct I was not
involved in Ukrainian affairs during the
Obama administration so I don't feel
competent to address that and
and ad Ukraine was put on pause I
believe you've testified that there may
have been concerned by secretary Kent
and by ambassador Taylor that it was
contributing to a potentially negative
effect on us
Ukraine relations do you agree with that
well the State Department position was
to advocate for the continuation of that
assistance as an important element in
fact a key element of our strategy to
support Russia that support the Ukraine
against Russia my time is expired I
yield back
mr. Himes Thank You mr. chairman thank
you to our witnesses for testifying
tonight I'm delighted to follow mr.
Radcliffe because he just perfectly
summarized the defense that my
Republican colleagues are mounting of
this behavior and the defense goes like
this the president is acting on some
deep historical concern
apparently invisible concern about
corruption and that because he's so
concerned about corruption in Ukraine
he's holding up aid and being prudent
and judicious the first part of that is
pretty easy to dispose of because
President Trump wasn't worried about
corruption in Ukraine in fact in the two
conversations he had with the president
of Ukraine on April 21st and July 25th
not once does the president of United
States use the word or mention
corruption to the president the second
part of that is a little bit more
interesting that he's just being prudent
and holding up aid that's not just wrong
it's illegal because miss Cooper and I
want you to help us walk through this
since the impoundment Control Act of
1974 the president has not had the
authority to on a whim or out of
prudence or as my Republicans say
because of a general skepticism of
foreign aid to stop foreign aid mr.
cooper under our Constitution it's the
Congress not the president that controls
the power of the purse correct yes sir
and the security assistant that was the
assistance that was authorized to
Ukraine was authorized and appropriated
by the Congress correct yes sir
so Congress is also concerned about
corruption it wants to ensure that a man
and foreign assistance is spent wisely
and does not worsen corruption and so
when Congress authorized this money it
built in conditions just as mr.
Radcliffe suggested by law Ukraine
wouldn't get all the money until it
demonstrated that it undertaken
substantial anti-corruption reforms
miss Cooper under the law the Department
of Defense works with the State
Department and other agencies to
establish anti-corruption benchmarks and
determine whether Ukraine has
sufficiently met those benchmarks
correct that's correct that provision
pertains to the Ukraine Security
Assistance initiative and that's not
that's a legally specified process
that's not the president in the Oval
Office manifesting a general skepticism
of foreign aid right that's a process it
is it is a congressionally mandated
process yes sir so did that process take
place for the DoD funding that was
helped held up in July so the process
that took place for the certification
took place prior to the May
certification to the US Congress so
right not only did it take place before
as required by law but months before
President Trump froze the money the
Department of Defense in consultation
with state sent a letter to Congress
certifying and you-you-you said this in
your opening statement the government of
Ukraine has taken substantial actions to
make defense institutional reforms for
the purposes of decreasing corruption
increasing accountability and sustaining
improvements of combat capability
enabled by US assistance so by the time
President Trump froze the aid the
Department of Defense had spent weeks if
not months determining that the
Ukrainian government met every
requirement in the law and made
significant strides in combating
corruption is that correct
as correct we made that determination in
May so this wasn't about corruption the
timeline proves it and in fact if there
was any doubt about what was going on
here the Chairman referred to your
inference
from the conversation with ambassador
Volker that if the Ukraine made a
statement committing to the
investigations the aid would be lifted
you covered that with a chairman and
then of course we have the press
conference of October 17th when Mick
Mulvaney let the cat Foley out of the
bag he revealed that President Trump
talked to him about and I quote Mick
Mulvaney here the corruption related to
the DNC server and admitted that quote
that's why we held up the money any
other explanation for the hold is a
farce now in my remaining 30 seconds
just tow that people understand what I
referred to in the 1970s Richard Nixon
just arbitrarily decided I don't know it
was because he had a general skepticism
of foreign aid or what his motives were
but Richard Nixon decided to hold up
congressionally-mandated aid and as a
result Congress went to work and passed
the impoundment Control Act of 1974
which prohibits the president from
withholding congressionally appropriated
funds without the approval of Congress
for any reason is that correct miss
Cooper sir I am not a lawyer but that
approximates my understanding of the
provision of the atomic okay I'll go
with that approximates thank you very
much now yield back the balance of my
time
it's the kind of way I think we're
sherwin mm-hmm as Paul Harvey said is
the rest of the story and my colleague
failed to put the right and fastest on
certain issues with respect to the
certification DoD certification was not
corruption writ large throughout the
entire country of Ukraine it was
narrowly focused on defense
institutional reforms and combat
capability isn't that correct mr. Cooper
that's correct sir my first thought was
Cooper thank you for being here this
afternoon I appreciate that but my
colleague seemed to leave that out as
original he read it when you reread your
statement but he left off the corrected
emphasis so the certification it may
didn't really speak to the broader
concept of corruption throughout the
rest of Ukraine that the president would
be familiar with the rest of us would be
familiar with sir the may certification
was specific to the defense sector or
defense industry and it did reference
the importance of civilian control of
the military
which relates more broadly to I think
all of us would argue or something would
argue event that fixes the corruption
throughout the rest of the country Cupra
maybe you can shed some light on the
specific details we talked about this
you just security assistance program 200
million some would argue that because
the pause that people died in August
because of the pause can you help us
understand exactly what obligated and
was there's things that were about to be
delivered to your crane was Ukraine out
of ammunition were they out of out of
javelins with out of all this stuff and
that because of this pause they didn't
get a certain lethal equipment that they
needed in order to protect their folks
during the month of August sir we will
deliver all of the I try to get a
timeline it there was no shortfall in
equipment deliveries that were expected
within that timeframe obligate means
that you're putting the funding on
contract okay and that's contract
starting the process yeah those four
contracts will be full fulfilled
fourth-quarter perhaps or whatever it
was
sir I have to say I'm a policy official
I am NOT a contracting expert but my
understanding is that we will be able to
make up for lost time in the contracting
process fantastic you go through three
or four steps as you went to because you
disagreed with the hole being placed on
on the assistance and I certainly agree
with that but did you get any kind of
criticism from the folks that you deal
with because you were going against the
one B's direction to put a hold on that
did you get criticized at all for that
absolutely not my entire chain of
command was supportive of advocating for
removing the hold on the funds and you
weren't restricted on the full throated
advocate advocating on behalf of getting
this whole lifter we're you know sir I
face no restrictions okay well thank you
for that I thought you might be more in
touch with extra specifics of the
accounting process and so I will defer
any further questions and again thanks
for being tonight I yield back
this whole Thank You mr. chairman
ambassador Hill I when did you actually
find out about the hold on the Ukraine
assistant was a July 21st yes I am in
the deposition that I did the closed
hearing I misspoke I was confused and I
confused June 21st which was one when
state first sent the CN up to this
congressional notification to OMB for
clearance it was only after about July
18 and I think the 21st is when I heard
that there was a potential hold thank
you for that clarification
now did you attend the July 26 deputies
meeting
deputies committee meeting that occurred
yes I did was it also your understanding
that the president directed the whole we
were told in that meeting by the OMB
representative that they were objecting
to proceeding with the assistance
because the president had so directed
through the chief of staff acting chief
of staff what was the State Department's
position regarding the whole state
department advocated as I did in a
meeting or proceeding with all of the
assistants consistent with our policies
and interests in Ukraine you believed
what you said you believed in the
release of the whole yes I did did
anyone at the interagency meeting at the
end of July support the whole did
anybody want the hold
remain and if so who what agency only
agency the only agency represented in
the meeting that indicated that they
supported the hold was OMB
miss Cooper did you understand similarly
that there was an overwhelming
interagency consensus to lift the hold
and that OMB
at the direction of the president was
the only roadblock
yes ma'am how is the security assistance
in the national security interests of
the United States
what is our interests explain that to my
constituents in Alabama who are
wondering why we should care about the
security the whole that's on the
security assistance yes ma'am this
specific assistance helps build the
capacity of the Ukrainian Armed Forces
and it's important to understand
and that these are forces that are
fighting to defend themselves against
Russian aggression every day it's an
ongoing war so they do need this
equipment to support their ability to
defend themselves and I would say
there's a larger issue here that relates
to US policy on Russia we believe it's
very important to strengthen the
capacity of Ukraine in order to deter
Russian aggression elsewhere around the
world
exactly were you ever able to get a
reason why that hold was on did you ever
get a reason no ma'am the only thing
that I heard about it but this is again
you know second third hand I'm was that
the president was concerned about
corruption but that was all I ever heard
so would you were you ever provided any
additional information about the reason
for the whole no ma'am I thank you and I
yield the balance of my time to the
Chairman I thank the gentlewoman my
colleagues a minority asked mr. Hale
wasn't it common to have holds on
military aid and I think you said
they're not unusual would you agree
though that it would be very unusual to
place a hold of military aid in order to
leverage a foreign country to get them
to investigate a political opponent yes
and I take it you would agree that that
would be completely inappropriate being
consistent with the conduct of our
foreign policy in general it would also
be wrong wouldn't it certainly not what
I would do
mr Turner of course would be interesting
if any witness had ever testified that
that was the case he owed my time to mr.
Jordan I thank the gentleman for
yielding personally I just wanted to go
where the Chairman started he said that
bastard Hale was one of our witnesses
they're all your witnesses you-you-you
called 17 witnesses you subpoenaed 15 of
them they're all your witnesses we
didn't get a subpoena anyone we didn't
to call anyone you gave us an
opportunity to get a
to you a couple weeks ago where we made
suggestions on who you might allow us to
have so we did put three people of those
17 on that list so that they can provide
at least some semblance of context and
framework for this entire thing so once
again trying misleading the the folks
watching this hearing is not not helpful
thank you both for being here and for
your service to our country ambassador I
read through yours ambassador to
Pakistan Lebanon special envoy the
Middle East ambassador to Jordan served
in Tunisia Bahrain Saudi Arabia Bend
about every hot spot on the planet thank
you for those hardship assignments we we
appreciate your your service let me go
first to earlier this today mister
Sandlin ambassador sahlan excuse me said
that he was denied access to some of his
records and the State Department put out
a statement they said this ambassador
Sandlin like every current Department of
State employee called before Congress in
this matter
retained at all times and continues to
retain full access to his State
Department documentary records and his
State Department email account which he
has always been fully free to access and
review at will that's an accurate
statement from the State Department
isn't it ambassador Hale I had not seen
it until shortly before entering this
hearing room but it sounds accurate yes
appreciate that ambassador you're aware
of no connection between the pause and
aid in exchange for any kind of
investigation is that correct I'm sorry
I missed a key word can you repeat the
question
you're you're not aware of any
connection between the pause and aid and
an exchange for some kind of
investigation being announced or done by
Ukraine
and you're not aware of secretary Pompeo
having any knowledge direct knowledge of
a connection between investigations and
security a sacrament I'm not aware of
that and he did not speak to me about
that you're not aware of any nefarious
motive to withhold aid to Ukraine is
that correct correct sir in fact you
testified that what you knew was that
president Trump was one skeptical of
foreign assistance generally mr.
Ratcliffe highlighted that in his round
of questioning and too skeptical of the
corruption
in Ukraine is that accurate well we had
heard that that was a general impression
at the State Department correct and the
aid was actually eventually released to
Ukraine is that correct as well yes I
read that sir
and there was just a 55-day or less than
two months pause and the actual hold on
the aid is that right
ambassador seem so yes correct and to
your knowledge as a top principal at the
State Department an investigation into
the Biden's BER yzma of the 2016
election never happened by the
Ukrainians is that correct I don't know
that I have the ability to answer that
question having taken this job in August
of 2018 oh well since you've taken the
job how about that to my knowledge
that's correct thank you I yield back
mr. Carson thank you chairman mr. cooper
ukraine is the first line of defense
against Russia's aggression and
expansion into Europe numerous witnesses
testify that Ukraine is in fact
vulnerable to Russian influence and
control your deposition sir you
testified that providing security
assistance is quote vital to helping the
Ukrainians be able to defend themselves
end quote what do you mean by that sir
that we have a long-standing policy of
helping Ukraine become a resilient state
in order to be able to defend itself we
want a reliable and resilient and
self-reliant security and economic
partner in Ukraine that can stand up to
Russian intimidation and aggression you
testified at the time of Russia's 2014
attack that the Ukrainian armed forces
were a quote significantly less capable
than it is today
unquote would you say sir that Ukrainian
forces were outmatched by Russia's
military in important ways I did not
start testify I think I'm ambassador
Hale and of course miss Cooper maybe
Cooper would you like to
I'm sorry I do believe that was my
deposition but could you just repeat the
question briefly so during the time of
Russia's 2014 attack the Ukrainian armed
forces were called significantly less
capable than it is today
would you say that Ukrainian forces were
outmatched by Russia's military and in
critical ways absolutely are the
Ukrainian forces now completely
self-sufficient in your mind essentially
in their ability to deter Russian
aggression no sir they they have a long
way to go would you say that the
Ukrainian Armed Forces now compar now
completely self-sufficient or how much
of an impact do does the US need to have
in terms of that deterrence and how
critical is a relationship between both
Ukraine and the US sir the Ukrainians
are on the right path to be able to
provide for their own security but they
will still need us and allied support
for quite some time and they need that
support in the form of you know tangible
assistance as well as political and
diplomatic support so this question is
to the both of you why was Russia's
illegal annexation of Crimea so
significant in your mind
Madame Cooper Russia violated the
sovereignty of Ukraine's territory
Russia illegally annexed territory that
belonged to Ukraine they also denied
Ukraine access to its naval fleet at the
time and to this day Russia is building
a capability on Crimea designed to
expand Russian military power projection
far beyond the immediate region in 2014
were there concerns in Washington here
in Washington and European capitals that
Russia might not stop in Ukraine I was
not in my current position in 2014 but
it is my understanding that there was
significant fear about where a Russian
aggression would stop
so what what what about today if the US
were to withdraw its military support of
Ukraine
what would effectively happen it is my
belief that if we were to withdraw our
support it would embolden Russia
it would also validate Russia's
violation of international law and which
a country stands to benefit the most
would stand to benefit the most from
such a withdrawal Russia ambassador
Taylor testified about the importance of
the u.s. upholding the international
system and it has underwritten peace in
Europe since the end of World War two a
critical aspect of defending that system
is ensuring that Russia cannot change
its borders by military force that is
why there are strong bipartisan support
or providing Ukraine with security
assistance that is why it is so
incredibly destructive of the President
of the United States to withhold this
assistance as part of a scheme to
pressure Ukraine into investigating at
the debunked conspiracy theory and
attack former Vice President Biden mr.
chairman I yield back
dr. winstram Thank You mr. chairman
thank you both for being here
as Army Reserve surgeon I can say as
both of you had that I served proudly
for two Republicans and two Democrats
presidents myself I want to go to part
with Cooper if I can page three I heard
the president had directed the Office of
Management and Budget to hold funds
because of his concerns about corruption
in Ukraine and you know you're coming
from the DoD side here you know I served
a year in Iraq and it was important and
I think it's something that the army
always does as I have seen that we don't
want to deliver aid or assistance if
there if it's going to some corrupt or
being delivered in some corrupt way in
other words if we're going to build a
medical treatment facility for the
Iraqis we want to make sure we're not
getting charged ten times as much I mean
we could
concerned about corruption in general
when we have delivering funds through
the DoD is it correct yes sir
so I think that that that's a normal
thing to do want to be concerned about
and we would do that in Iraq and
especially if we're providing payment
for something so I just want to go
through a few things with you because
multiple witnesses have testified that
the action to provide javelins to
Ukraine by the Trump administration
demerant demonstrated strong us support
to Ukraine ambassador Jovanovic in her
deposition said President Trump's
decision to provide lethal weapons to
Ukraine that our policy actually got
stronger over the last three years
she also said in terms of lethal
assistance we all felt it was very
significant with this administer that
this administration made the decision to
provide lethal weapons to Ukraine vassar
Taylor said it was a substantial
improvement in that this administration
provided javelin anti-tank weapons very
strong political message it said the
Americans are willing to provide more
than blankets ambassador Volcker
testified that providing lethal
defensive arms to Ukraine has been
extremely helpful mr. Volker also stated
MREs and blankets and all that's fine
but if you're being attacked with
mortars and artillery and tanks you need
to be able to fight back secretary
George Kent stated that javelins are
incredibly effective weapons at stopping
armed advance and the Russians are
scared of them
special advisor Catherine Croft stated
the javelins help Ukraine defend
themselves a decision to provide
javelins we believe is counter to
Russian interest do do you dispute what
these witnesses have testified to an
including ambassador Ivanovich Taylor
Volker and others sir I absolutely agree
that the javelin system is an important
capability and that this was a very
important decision to support Ukraine
with this capability thank you and you
already testified that you're personally
proud of the Trump administration's
decision to arm Ukraine with javelins
correct that is correct sir
so one of the things on page 3 tonight
you're talking about meeting July 26 and
after that you said I was aware the
national security community expressed
unanimous support for resuming the
funding as in the u.s. national security
interests that's correct you said that
tonight correct sir
so I guess I take a little question with
resuming because we don't want to resume
as is would that be correct because as
is would not include javelin sir I'm not
sure I'm following well what I was
saying the previous administration
javelins were not provided even though
they could have been right President
Obama stopped the javelins he could have
delivered javelins let's put that way
sir I think I should clarify what I
meant by that statement resuming was
just referring to the fact that OMB had
placed a hold on the assistance so we
weren't spending okay and I wanted to
resume the spending
okay well that we could maintain this
policy and maintain the strain tain the
policy but I guess what I'm asking there
is a difference and I think under
secretary Hale you might I thought I saw
you nodding the difference being that as
it's resumed in this case now it
included javelins which the Obama
administration denied is that correct
it is true that the Trump administration
approved the release of defensive lethal
assistance to include javelin
whereas the previous administration did
not support that policy mr. Hill do you
have comment on that that seems correct
I defer to mr. Cooper is the okay well I
think we can conclude that more than
blankets and MREs has been helping the
Ukrainians and the lethal defensive
weapons are something the Trump
administration has approved and it's a
benefit to all of us thank you miss
Speier Thank You mr. chairman thank you
both for being here this evening you
know there's this mystery surrounding
the hold on the aid in in July it
appears but back in May miss Cooper I
believe you said that there was a that
was conditioned but you certified in May
that the conditions had been met and
they include included progress on
command and control reform commitment to
pursue defense industry reform and pass
laws to enable government to government
procurement is that correct yes ma'am
that's correct so then when you find out
in July that they're concerned about
corruption you're scratching our head
right so yes ma'am we didn't have your
stand and do you know of any effort that
was undertaken then to assess the
corruption in Ukraine in June July
August ma'am as I believe I said in my
deposition the only specific discussions
that I am aware of related to that
series of interagency meetings the sub
PCC as we called it the PCC policy
coordination committee and the deputies
small group and in those meetings
participants did discuss the degree to
which corruption was a concern and the
degree to which there was progress and
my recollection of what the participant
said in these meetings was that there
was a very positive sense that progress
was being made so you have these
meetings progress is being made nothing
really changes from May until September
that would then trigger the release of
the money except a whistleblower came
forward ma'am I do not know what
triggered the release of the funding all
right
the fact that there was reference made
to money being withheld in or other
countries was made by some of our
colleagues but in those situations in
countries like Pakistan
Lebanon I am here for people wondering
we're just getting ready for the debate
stream tonight so I'll jump in when
necessary but we're just letting it run
for now so I cannot answer that question
hey well I've been told that that is
indeed the case so that there's not the
the immediate angst or hit financially
that would potentially accrue but the
difference as I see it in Ukraine as
compared to these other countries is
that Ukraine is engaged in the hot war
with Russia right now and it seems that
withholding that money was irresponsible
considering that they had made all of
this taken steps to meet all the
conditions that we had requested of them
and Congress had appropriated the funds
is that not the case ma'am I and my DoD
colleagues advocated strenuously for the
release of these funds because of their
national security importance so
basically the entire interests of the
Department of Defense and State
Department were consistently supportive
of releasing this funds everyone was
mystified as to why the funds had been
withheld and everyone's running around
trying to get an answer and you're
getting kind of obtuse responses saying
it was the president because of
corruption now what we see is that
President Solinsky gets elected in April
the expectation is that vice president
Pence is going to attend the
inauguration in September and then the
president pulls the carpet out from
under him in terms of him going and then
he proceeds in June or July to withhold
the funds there is a concerted effort by
the president the United States to to
act in a manner that is not consistent
with our interest in wanting to protect
Ukraine and help them deal with the
Russian aggression at its border
would you agree with that ma'am I have
you know advocated for the security
assistance and I have advocated for
high-level engagement with the
government of Ukraine because I think
both are in the national security
interest
I yield back mr. Stewart Thank You
chairman undersecretary sick assistant
secretary thank you both for being here
you're both recognized as experts
dedicated public servants that I got to
tell you being the president adapts the
most complicated endeavor in the history
of the world no one could do it without
people like you to provide that backbone
that you do and thank you for doing that
I don't mean to repeat the same
questions ad nauseam but I think we
reached a point of nauseam I don't know
sometime yesterday or some time ago it's
some repetitive here and you'll forgive
me for doing that although mr. Cooper I
do have some some questions based on
some things you've said previously and I
would just want to add for clarification
there's a question about these emails
that I think they claimed withholding
described withholding the ADA and they
had come from Capitol Hill or from
someone on the Foreign Affairs Committee
is that true sir are you referring to my
statement today or something I believe
this is previous question we had
previous are you aware of such an email
I'm sorry I don't think I have enough
information to make an assessment is it
from a particular page in my deposition
no it's just reporting that we've heard
that there may have been communications
buit to you with someone on the Foreign
Affairs Committee on the hill is that is
that not true that there may have been
communications with me yes email with
you sir I'm not I'm not aware okay thank
you
and for clarification as well someone
may have asked you or queried you from
the Ukrainian embassy about the
withholding of aid is that true did you
hear from them
sir I testified earlier that the
communication from the Ukrainian embassy
was to my staff and my staff mentioned
this to me after my deposition
the only specific communication that I
recollect with the Ukrainians about this
specific issue was on I believe it was
September 5th at a reception at the
Ukrainian Embassy and just a bore down
on that just a little bit was that just
a query generally about the forthcoming
aid or was a specific regarding them
being aware that the aid was being
withheld sir just to be clear the
September 5th conversation that I had
was specific to the hold there there was
an awareness of that and there was a
question of concern okay thank you you
know miss Cooper well to both of you
undersecretary Hill as well at the end
of the day it really does and I've done
this before it really does come down to
this the transcript I'm holding up is a
transcript of the phone call between
President Solinsky and President Trump
that IO would hope every American would
take the opportunity to read it's only a
few pages long and and much more
information beyond that is may be
helpful to inform but it really I have
to comment on this it's only a few pages
long because they didn't release the
entire thing it's the 30 minute phone
call and there's like six pages which
you can read in five or six minutes
questions and I have your answers here
so this won't take long
and you've answered them generally
anyway you agree the United States
should evaluate whether country is
worthy of our aid is that fair to say
yes sir and you understand as well the
President Trump has been skeptical
generally a foreign aid and some of the
money that we've given is that fair as
well I think so and I think that's being
fairly consistent he's done that since
before he was elected I think others in
the process of testified the crane has a
long history of corruption that's not
going to surprise any one of us we've
talked about that about a thousand times
do you think it was right the president
tell what would test is the word I think
used previously that he would test
president szalinski prior to review to
providing some of the security
assistance the president Solinsky was
new I had met him in February I was
impressed by him but I think it was
understandable for the administration as
a new president in Ukraine was coming to
office to understand better what that
president's policies would be and
attitude toward the United States and
see I'm your secretary I think that's
because we've had it referred to while
the DoD had completed their review about
the same time but this was a person who
was elected and we knew nothing about
him
he didn't have a history of governance
in Ukraine he came really a little bit
like President Trump himself he did not
come from a public background that we
would have much information on him and
it seems prudent as he said to kind of
test him and see if he was serious about
Ukraine at some point I'm going to
conclude I believe is about labor day
the Secretary was able to engage a
president on the Security Assistance
about the same time by the way that you
had some others secretary vice president
pants and Bolton's and Bolton as well as
well as a burden-sharing
review was completed and shortly
thereafter the aid was released is that
your understanding um
I was never informed as to why the
assistance was released I did read about
it okay well those events did happen and
it seemed like they were the reason the
aid was released but thank you both and
I yield back mr. Quigley thank you thank
you both for being here and thank you
for your service
you've both been asked about the
importance of this military assistance
as it affects Ukrainian sovereignty and
its importance because of potential
greater ambitions by the Russians I try
to put it in context and please get your
reaction from from both of you from
someone who had been there before a
renowned international policy expert on
such things
Zigman of Brzezinski his quote seems to
strike home today
he wrote Russia can either be an empire
or a democracy but it cannot be both
without Ukraine Russia ceases to be an
empire but with Ukraine suborned and
then subordinated Russia automatically
becomes an empire your thoughts of how
this puts this into context today please
sir I think that is a very powerful and
accurate quote I would agree
the scooper you talked about emails that
were drawn to your attention that you
were they were sent to your staff is
that correct the emails that I discussed
this evening were email sent to my staff
that is correct
okay I think first of all it's important
to point this out that it's not
something you are aware of it points to
a larger issue that the Defense
Department the State Department have
refused to comply with a duly issued
subpoena to provide this committee with
documents that would further shed light
on when precisely Ukrainians knew about
the hold so this isn't something you're
aware of but there is untold information
out there being blocked that would draw
a greater light and help us understand
is there anything else out there that
you're aware of or possibilities that
are out there with DoD or the State
Department which could help us shed
light on what the Ukrainians knew and
when they knew it sir I have shared with
the committee all that I recollect but I
have not done an exhaustive
investigation so I really can't
speculate on what else might be
available by combing through all of the
Defense Department records which are
substantial did the State Department or
Department of fenced ask you for your
information or did you they coordinate
with you to get information you had sir
I was told not to not to destroy
anything and our our IT personnel have
been collecting documents as my
understanding so that that occurs
without without the individual having to
but they were collecting it and passing
it on to state or DoD is that correct
I'm sorry sir could you they were you
said your department was collecting it
well they weren't passing that on to you
they were passing it on to the State
Department sir army of Defense this is
what they reported to me I have not seen
the documents that have been collected I
only know those documents
that I have produced or that my staff
has brought to my attention or that I
have received so no I do not know what
has happened with the documents that
have been collected same general
question to you sir I requested and was
granted access to documents that I
either originated or that had been sent
to me that were relevant to the
pertinent matters of this investigation
during a finite time period I don't have
really information about what else is
going on in terms of other documents
that I did not produce sort of I did not
receive and you know I there was a move
to gather them and I understood
generally indirectly and informally that
they have been gathered that's the
extent of my knowledge is not my area of
responsibility yes but did they pass
them on to you or did they pass them on
to the administration and somehow the
only documents I received sir were those
within the parameters I described what I
requested which was those and given were
the documents that either I produced or
that were sent to me relevant to the
matters we're discussing today thank you
I yield back to the Chairman mr. funny
thank you to both of our witnesses for
your service today
ms Cooper I wanted to start with you you
spoke eloquently of the threat of Russia
when it illegally annexed Crimea how
that's a threat not only to Ukraine but
it's also a threat to Europe and the
United States a national security
challenge and I sit on the House Armed
Services Committee we know that the most
important support for Ukraine in terms
of lethal defensive aid is in the forms
of javelins would you agree with that
yes ma'am and would administration were
those javelins made available to Ukraine
this administration in the Trump
administration and not the Obama
administration that is correct both of
you have you ever spoken with the
president about Ukraine aid no I have
not ma'am
Under Secretary Hale you testified that
you had no direct knowledge of any
nefarious motivations to withhold aid to
Ukraine correct correct
and to your knowledge you testify that
there were no strings attached
to the aid correct that's page 184 of
your deposition
yeah no such knowledge and more
specifically you testify that you had no
knowledge of Ukraine aid being held up
for investigations is that correct
Rick during the temporary hold of
security assistance this was until
ambassador Taylor sent you the cable you
had never even heard the word charisma
or Biden correct well in the context of
what we're discussing correct great you
testified that on page 96 and ultimately
as we know the aide was released to
Ukraine correct yes I read that now
let's talk about the contacts broadly of
this hold you testified that it's not
just Ukraine that there were in fact
other countries whose security
assistance was on hold
quote the aid package to Lebanon was
also being held in the same fashion
correct Rick and foreign aid was held
from northern triangle countries of
South America correct of Central America
correct Central America and you also
testified that when you served as
ambassador to Pakistan security
assistance was also held for their
failure to conform to our concerns
regarding terrorists and other issues on
the afghan-pakistan border correct you
know basically let's broadly talk about
the context of all of these holds on aid
when we talk about aid I always think
about these are hard-earned taxpayer
dollars would you agree with that
absolutely and isn't it correct that
this administration the Trump
administration has been conducting a
foreign assistance review to
re-establish norms that guide the
assistance as we provide aid overseas
that's correct you testified that this
review had been going on for quite a
while and the administration did not
want to take a business-as-usual
approach to foreign assistance a feeling
that once a country has received a
certain assistance package it's
something that continues forever and you
continued the program had to be
evaluated that they were actually worthy
beneficiaries of our assistance that our
program made sense that we avoid
nation-building strategies and that we
provide assistance to countries that are
at our loss
in terms of our policy to our
adversaries that correct that's correct
and you testify that you warmly welcomed
this assistance review for it and again
just just to get this on record and for
the millions of Americans viewing
security assistance was in fact released
to Ukraine I know I've already asked
this but this is a really important
point correct thank you I yield back mr.
swallow miss Cooper your testimony today
destroys two of the pillars of the
president's defense and one
justification for his conduct first
pillar no harm no foul the Ukrainians
didn't know that the hold was in place
so didn't really hurt them second pillar
this president was a real champion of
anti-corruption and he cared about
corruption in Ukraine so I want to go
through your new testimony today it's
your testimony now that after an
employee came forward to you you believe
you have some evidence that the
Ukrainians first inquired about security
assistance to someone in your office on
July 25 of this year is that right
that's correct
July 25 is also the day that President
Trump officially talked to President
Solinsky where investigations of the
Biden's were brought up is that right
sir I only know what has been reported
publicly on this and that was reported
is that right
that's correct second this president as
a champion of anti-corruption your
testimony today is that on May 23 you
certified that as far as it related to
your duties Ukraine had met the
corruption concerns for the aid to be
released is that right sir the Defense
Department certified and after that date
inexplicably the president the United
States puts a hold on security
assistance is that right that was what I
heard in July yes now this
anti-corruption president who cares so
much about rooting out corruption in
Ukraine did he ever call you after the
put the hold to say miss Cooper what's
going on in Ukraine no sir
ambassador Heil did he ever call you to
ask about an update on Ukraine
corruption no sir
to your knowledge did he ever call your
boss secretary Pompeo I don't know miss
Cooper did he ever call the many bosses
that you've had at the Department of
Defense secretaries are acting
secretaries I don't know sir now as to
the justification the justification is
that the Obama administration only
provided blankets so the Ukrainians
should be grateful even after being
shaken down that the Trump
administration provided more but the
truth miss Cooper is that under the
Obama administration and the European
reassurance initiative 175 million
dollars were provided from US taxpayer
dollars to the Ukrainians is that right
sir I don't have that figure the figure
that we typically use is to say we've
provided 1.6 billion dollars to date and
we you know but I don't have the
breakdown in front of me and the Obama
administration also trained five
military battalions of the Ukrainians is
that correct again I don't have the
figures in front of me but yes the
training program began in the Obama
administration and we did train many
forces and under the Obama
administration founded Ukrainian
security assistance initiative provided
to the Ukrainians were armored Humvees
tactical drones night-vision devices
armored vests and medical equipment is
that correct it's all sound like pieces
of equipment that were provided in the
Obama administration to my recollection
you'd agree that's a lot more than
blankets right yes sir
ambassador Hale the aid that was
withheld to Lebanon and Pakistan those
were for legitimate foreign policy
objectives is that right I would say
that's true the assistance to Pakistan
I've not heard an explanation for the
current hold on the Lebanese program and
you would agree that withholding aid to
investigate a political opponent is not
a legitimate foreign policy objective is
that right correct so I guess we can
agree
that even Bernie Madoff made charitable
contributions but doesn't make him a
good guy miss Cooper
your testimony today demonstrates the
power of coming forward and defying
lawless orders from the president
because you came forward and testified
we learned this new information which
destroys a central defense that the
Republicans have put forward because
ambassador Taylor came forward one of
his employees learned this defense from
the Republicans that all we had was
hearsay evidence and mr. Holmes said
actually I heard the President of the
United States
tell ambassador Sandlin where are we
with the investigations your courage has
aided this investigation despite the
president's continued obstruction I
yield back
mr. hurt Thank You chairman ambassador
Hale you're in essence the number three
guy at the State Department is that
correct correct
you represent roughly 70,000 folks or
you which I represent them I'm part of
them on one of them yes will you where
you are part of a pretty fantastic
workforce that I've been proud to be
able to serve alongside we we share time
together in in Pakistan and so thank
them I know they oftentimes don't get
the Pat's on the back or the accolades
for what they do for our national
security but there's some of us that do
recognize that and appreciate that
did anybody raise issues to you and
ambassador Hill about investigations the
Biden's
or burries ma no sir thank you miss
Cooper you have a great staff I don't
think my staff would have read my a
hundred and fifteen page deposition and
gave me feedback so I give them give
them gold stars you said in your in your
deposition and you just confirm with my
colleague from
for Nia that she's certified on 23 May
that the Ukraine aid for the the review
of the departed defense industry and
Department of Defense you know was
passed the corruption tests is that
correct sir I think the wording was more
along the lines of progress has been
made or sufficient progress has been
made it didn't it didn't reference any
kind of an anti-corruption test per se
um did this change or was there a
revaluation with a new president coming
in because president Solinsky was
inaugurated in office two days before
that date did that have an impact on how
he was going to continue some of those
some of those pieces was that taken into
account in this review not prior to May
23rd no sir so the review was basically
done on the previous the efforts done by
the previous poroshenko administration
yes sir although it's important to note
that the review related most
specifically to the Ministry of Defense
sure sure but there were ultimately
changes under the under these Alinsky
regime is that correct yes sir there's a
new Minister of Defence um can you
explain I know FMF a foreign military
financing of State Department's but can
you explain the difference between FMF
and USA I funding and and also how the
Ukrainians get lethal aid I'm sorry
could you repeat the last part of that
also how the Ukrainians actually get
lethal aid because is lethal aid covered
under one of these two buckets so there
are three separate pieces to our overall
ability to provide equipment to the
Ukrainian Armed Forces the first is the
foreign military finance system which is
a State Department Authority and
countries around the world have this
Authority that authority is used for
some of the training and equipment
there's also the Ukraine Security
Assistance initiative that's a DoD
Authority unlike the state authority the
DoD authority is owned
one year authority and then third
there's opportunity for defense sales
and that is something that we're working
with the Ukrainians on now so that they
can actually purchase us equipment
what's a javelin specifically was
provided under FMF initially and now the
Ukrainians are interested in the
purchase of javelin and there wasn't a
hold put on purchasing of equipment is
that correct not to my understanding no
can I ask you an on impeachment inquiry
question miss Gupta and on what an on
impeachment inquiry question sir my time
is yours what can we be doing to help
the Ukrainians defend against Russian
electronic warfare what more can we be
doing to help the Ukrainians defend
against elec electronic warfare by the
Russians well what I can say in an open
hearing is that there actually is some
electronic warfare detection equipment
that is included in the USA I package so
there there's a piece of capability that
we're already working to provide them I
think this specific topic though is more
suitable for a closed-door session
that's a good copy
thanks for both of y'all service to our
country and chairman I yield back mr.
Castro Thank You chairman and thank you
all for your testimony today I want us
to make an important distinction here
because the field my colleagues have
rattled off countries where we've
actually held up aid there is a big
distinction between holding up aid for a
legitimate policy reason foreign policy
reason and holding up a because it's
part of a shakedown because it's in the
service of a president who asked for a
political favor of a country to go
investigate a political rival I think
that's important for us to note and I
want to ask you
miss Cooper you said that the money was
cleared to go by the DoD on May 23rd is
that right that's correct
and it didn't get released until
September 11 yes I should just clarify
the second half of the Ukraine security
assistance initiative was notified to
Congress on I believe it was May 23rd
and then there was a waiting period for
congressional approval and then after
that point so in kind of mid-june
roughly it was available
so perhaps 90 days or so 95 days
something like that well you both
testified that the hold on security
assistance was not in the national
security interest of the United States
and that the hold might embolden Russia
we've heard the same from numerous other
witnesses that have come before us but
this was not the only issue with the
whole right we understand that people
within the United States government had
significant concerns about the legality
of the hold as it relates to the
impoundment Control Act this is because
the money had been authorized by
Congress and signed into law by
President Trump miss Cooper at the July
meetings were there any discussions
about whether the hold could be
implemented in a legal fashion so in the
July 26th meeting my leadership raised
the question of how the president's
guidance could be implemented and
proffered that perhaps a reprogramming
action would be the way to do this but
that more research would need to be done
so then after that discussion we had a
lower-level discussion at my level on
the 31st of July and let me ask you
about that July 31st meeting based on
your conversations with colleagues at
the DoD at the July 31st interagency
meeting did you share your understanding
of illegal legal mechanisms that were
available at that time yes sir
and what were they I expressed that it
was my understanding that there were two
ways that we would be able to implement
presidential guidance to stop obligating
the Ukraine security assistance
initiative and the first option would be
for the president to do a rescission the
second is a reprogramming action that
the Department of Defense would do and
both of those would require
congressional
notice yes there would be an extra step
that the president would have to take to
notify Congress as far as you know was
there ever any notice that was sent out
to Congress sir I didn't express that
that I believed it would require notice
to Congress and that then there was no
such notice to my knowledge or
preparation of such a notice to my
knowledge and as far as you know there
was never any official rescission or
reprogramming of that money no sir not
to my knowledge instead what happened
was OMB device an alternative solution
involving creative footnotes to
implement the hold and there came a time
in August when the Department of Defense
no longer supported these unusual
footnotes because of concerns that there
might not be sufficient time for DoD to
obligate the funds before the end of the
fiscal year in violation of the
impoundment Control Act so despite the
Odie's concerns in mid-august about the
impoundment Control Act and OMB
footnotes the hold nevertheless
continued through September 11th even
after now as an aside this is even after
the whistleblower had come forward is
that right it is correct that the hold
was released on September 11th yes well
I know I and many of us here shared
DoD's concerns about the legality of the
hold and I want to thank you miss Cooper
for voicing DoD's concerns to the White
House and pursuing the national security
interests of the United States
I yield back mr. Atif chairman mr.
cooper based on the new emails that you
mentioned in your opening and then
subsequent declarations by some of my
Democratic colleagues that those emails
were evidence that the Ukrainians were
aware of a military hold on July 25th
there's now reporting out there saying
that Pentagon official reveals
Ukrainians asked about stalled security
aid it's it's being widely reported that
Ukraine asked about the hold on military
aid on July 25th that's not what I heard
from you is that correct sir my exact
Wordsworth at one email said that the
Ukrainian Embassy and the House Foreign
Affairs Committee are asking about
security assistance assistance not hold
and then the second email was the hill
knows about the FMF situation to an
extent and so does the Ukrainian embassy
those are the exact words
and what do security assistance and FMF
situation in these emails mean I don't
want to speculate on what it means right
they don't necessarily mean hold correct
not necessarily and isn't it true that
around the same time OMB put a hold on
15 State Department and USAID accounts
including FMF I don't know that specific
detail but you can't say one way or
another whether the enquiries in these
emails were about the hold is that fair
I cannot say for certain and you can't
say one way or another whether the
Ukrainians knew about the hold before
August 28 2019 when it was reported in
Politico correct sir I can just tell you
that it's the recollection of my staff
that they likely knew but no I do not
have a certain data point to offer you
well it's not unusual is it miss Cooper
for foreign countries to inquire about
foreign aid that they're expecting from
the United States is it sir in my
experience with the Ukrainians they
typically would call about specific
things not just generally checking in on
their assistance package are you aware
that president szalinski on October 10th
in response to questions from more than
300 reporters over the course of the
afternoon stated that he was not aware
and had no knowledge of a hold on
security assistance during the time of
his July 25th phone call with President
Trump I believe I saw that media
reporting yes I yield back
let's track Thank You mr. chairman I
think you both for being here this
evening ambassador Hale last week the
country watched as president Trump
attacked and intimidated your colleague
he attempted to intimidate your
colleague ambassador Jovanovic who is of
course a witness to this proceeding and
subsequently secretary Pompeo declined
to condemn that attack bluntly put I
think Secretary's secretary Pompeo
silence is nothing less than a betrayal
of the men and the women whom he swore
an oath to lead and it's it's a betrayal
that has long-term consequences to
attracting and retaining retaining
workforce to their morale to their
effectiveness and to their overall
strength so ambassador Hale I want to
give you an opportunity to now do what
secretary Pompeo did not do either in
March of 2019 when the vicious smear
campaign kind of got kicked into high
gear and you sir rightfully pressed for
a strong statement in support of her or
last week when the president and his son
attacked at her attacked her again
I'm offering you the opportunity to
reaffirm to this committee and the
millions of Americans hopefully who are
watching that Marie Ivanovitch is a
dedicated and courageous patriot and
that she served with grace and dignity
even in the face of that orchestrated an
unsubstantiated smear attack against her
ambassador Hale I'm giving you the
opportunity to demonstrate leadership
I'm giving you the opportunity to send a
clear and resounding message to the men
and women who serve in dangerous foreign
posts throughout the globe that what
happened to Marie Jovanovic
what's wrong ambassador Heil the floor
is yours
Thank You congressman excuse me I
endorse entirely your description of
ambassador Jovanovic I only met her when
I took this job but immediately I
understood that we had an exceptional
officer doing exceptional work at a very
critical Embassy in Keith and during my
visits to Keith I was very impressed by
what she was doing there to the extent
that I asked her if she'd be willing to
stay if that was a possibility because
we had a cap coming up I support and
believe in the institution and the
people of the State Department I am one
of them I have been for 35 years all of
us are committed to America's national
security and we are the best group of
diplomats anywhere in the world and that
support extends to all state officers
who have testified before this committee
if I may I'd like to read a letter that
the undersecretary for management wrote
on November 18 to the ranking member of
the Senate Foreign Relations Committee
in response to a communication from him
a number of Department employees have
testified before the House of
Representatives during its inquiry
regarding Ukraine no employee has faced
any adverse action by the department for
testimony before Congress on this matter
the Department will not discipline any
department employee for appearing before
Congress in response to a subpoena the
department has also proactively
established a program to provide
financial assistance with respect to
private counsel deagle fees incurred by
Department employees there's additional
information but that's the essence of
the message ambassador Hale then
therefore are you saying aria Voinovich
is a dedicated and courageous patriot I
do endorse what you say exactly and then
she served with grace and dignity in the
face of the smear campaign yes she did
and that what happened to her was wrong
I believe that she should have been able
to stay at post and continue to do the
outstanding work and what happened to
her was wrong that's right thank you sir
thank you for clarifying the record
because I wasn't sure where it was that
she could go to set the record straight
if it wasn't you sir or where she could
go to get her good name and reputation
back if it weren't if it wasn't you sir
indeed I want to encourage you in the
strong
this terms possible stand your ground
America's security and strength and
prosperity is predicated in no small
part on the professionalism of our
foreign services core and they need to
know that you is the highest ranking
professional diplomat in the entire
State Department have their back sir
thank you for having ambassador
Jovanovic us back this evening and with
that mr. chair I yield back mr. Jordan
Thank You mr. chairman mr. Cooper the
who why did the Office of Management and
Budget put a hold on the funds sir the
only information that I received was
from the Office of Management and Budget
that they were operating at the
direction of the president and they
reported that he had concerns about
corruption that is all that I put that
in your testimony President had direct
the Office of Management budget to hold
the funds because of his concerns about
corruption in Ukraine very legitimate
reason you agree that is the this
statement that the president reportedly
made as reported to me by the Office of
Management and Budget and then you said
in your testimony that based on
recommendations from me and other key
DoD advisors the Department of Defense
in coordination with Department of State
certified in May of 2019 that Ukraine
had taken the steps necessary and you
certified the release of the dollars is
that accurate that is correct sir
but there was you know there was a small
change in Ukraine in the spring of 2019
wasn't there yes sir yeah and can you
elaborate on what that change was the
government of well president Solinsky
was elected to government yeah you got a
brand new guy coming in in fact he had
just been I believed sworn in the day
you approved that the dollars was a May
23rd I think he was sworn in on the bag
it was a couple days before but there's
sort of a sort of a change in
circumstances that it seemed to me would
warrant at least maybe a second
and that's exactly what played out for a
short time less than two months 55 days
the our government evaluated the new
situation pretty radical change you got
a new government in fact the previous
one we've heard all kinds of things from
from the Democrats about the prosecutor
general and the poroshenko regime mr.
Lutz Inc oh and how bad he was so it
took a while for that to that all to
happen new presidents sworn in two
months later the new Congress comes in
takes them a while to it's not until
September September 5th that they get
rid of this prosecutor in just a few
days later the 8th actually gets
released but the Democrats got all kinds
of other things they want to talk about
but the way this played out seems to me
as logical as you can you can do it and
particularly when you put it in the
broader framework of where this
president is on concern about foreign
aid is deep rooted concern in the
corruption issue in Ukraine the
experience he had with high-ranking
Ukrainian officials criticizing him and
supporting Secretary Clinton in the 2016
election put all that together sort of I
think shows why it played out the way it
did that I would yield back mr. chairman
mr. Welch Thank You mr. chairman
under secretary Hale I want to go back
to your support and affirmation of
ambassador Jovanovic what I understand
and by the way thank you for that you
know our military leaves nobody on no
soldier on the battlefield and I think
those who are in leadership positions in
the State Department and our
intelligence community have that bond of
loyalty to each other and it's very
reassuring that you represent that you
first as I understand it got information
her situation in March by early March
secretary Pompeo had mentioned that some
time the followed received a letter from
a former member of Congress with
complaints about the ambassador correct
and that rhetoric that member Congress
was congressman sessions and did you see
that there was any basis to the claims
of disloyalty no I did not nor did the
Secretary of State all right you visited
Keefe and you discussed in fact
extending ambassador Jovanovic just
terms until to remain in her post right
it was a personal idea of mine yes
obviously a indication that you valued
her continued service there and you also
stated to the Ukrainian press that
ambassador Jovanovic represents the
president of the United States here in
the Ukraine in America stands behind her
statements obviously trying to give her
some public support correct correct
and yet weeks later the President and
mr. Giuliani unleashed what can only be
characterized as an ugly smear campaign
to him by to to oust her what was your
reaction to the news articles in late
March in which a corrupt Ukrainian
prosecutor attacked the ambassador well
we were concerned we put out a statement
that some of these allegations are an
outright fabrication as they related to
the do not prosecute list and we began
to discuss what we could do to deal with
this matter right and then the problems
continued for ambassador Jovanovic and
as I understand it she emailed you on
March 24th and indicated that quote the
temple of social media and other
criticisms were such that she felt she
could no longer function unless there
was a strong statement of defense of her
from the debate State Department is that
correct correct and this message what
secretary Pompeo was aware of her
situation is that correct yes i briefed
him the next day and he's the ultimate
authority who could issue that strong
statement of support correct correct but
he never ever did issue a statement
right we did not issue a statement at
that time but in fact
yes I you testified around the same time
that the secretary did not render
assistance to a long-serving and highly
respected ambassador he made two phone
calls to Rudy Giuliani is that right
that's correct that he has seen a record
that he made those phone calls one on
March 28th and again the next day and
March 29
I saw the record of that yes right so we
don't know what he said to Rudy Giuliani
but we have a pretty good idea what Rudy
Rudy Giuliani said to him get rid of
Jovanovic
she was gone and the statement never
came forward right correct and when she
was recalled and wanted to find out what
happened Secretary Pompeo would not meet
with her I was out of the country at the
time I can't comment on that all right
what and then mr. Breck Beale who was
next in line didn't meet with her I
don't know this well they came for you
to give her the news it went to the
deputy secretary I believe held the
meeting I was a in fawn foreign travel
at the time well be interesting if he
could have secretary Pompeo be here to
tell us what his conversations were with
Rudy Giuliani the person who was
fomenting the discontent about an
ambassador for who was fighting
corruption I want to thank you and I
want to thank miss Cooper for your
service miss Maloney hello miss Cooper
secretary Hale Cooper thank you for
working late on a Wednesday the last
time we attempted to hear your testimony
the Republicans were good enough to
bring pizza down to the skiff
but kidding aside I I know we detained
you for about five hours that day so on
behalf of the committee thank you for
your forbearance we do appreciate your
patience with us a quick question for
you and and I think just one question
for you secretary Hale
miss Cooper was DoD able to put all the
security system funds into contract
before the end of the fiscal year
no sir and how much was were they not
able to obligate what was left on the
obligated I believe the figure was 35
million its we were able to actually
obligate 88% total and I think you
mentioned that you were able because of
legislation the Congress passed
continuing resolution to do that is that
right so the remainder we are in the
process of obligation right now because
of the the provision in the continuing
resolution right so but for a literally
an act of Congress you couldn't have
spent all the money if we had not
received the provision in the continuing
resolution we would have obligated
eighty eight percent but not the full
amount right which of course would be a
violation of law to not spend money that
Congress appropriated sir I am NOT a
lawyer but that is my understanding
sure Thank You secretary Hale where were
you born
Ann Arbor Michigan and each family from
Ireland am I right about that no sir I'm
sorry striking another question with
respect to secretary Ivanovitch you
served as ambassador to I believe three
countries correct Jordan Jordan Lebanon
nightstand Pakistan Lebanon and while
you were ambassador to those three
countries did anyone ever ask you to
issue a support praising personally the
president United States no how would you
viewed such requests depend on the
situation sir someone said say you went
to someone and you were having problem
with your job and you said how can I do
better and they said you should publish
something personally praising the
president flattering to him with that
strike you as unusual yes if someone
told you to go big or go home would that
change your mind I don't quite
understand the well that's what
ambassador Jovanovic was treated to when
she went to ambassador Sol and seeking
advice
and and she declined to do so I believe
she said it which striker is too
political is that consistent with the
approach the approach you might take I
thought that sounds sensible yes thank
you you remaining time back to the
Chairman thank you both for being here
there's Emily's ambassador Hale miss
Cooper thank you both for being with us
just a quick question before I get into
some questions about ambassador Sandlin
who we heard from today I want to ask
both of you if President Trump withheld
critical military aid from Ukraine
because high-ranking officials supported
the president's political opponent would
you consider that an official acceptable
appropriate action by the President of
the United States Ambassador Hale it's
not what I would advise miss Cooper no
that doesn't that sound appropriate
ambassador Hale you testified that you
were aware ambassador Sandlin was
involving himself in matters that and I
quote went beyond the normal wit writ of
the of an ambassador to the European
Union unquote as you understood it who
authorized ambassador Sandlin to work on
Ukraine
I have no first-hand knowledge of that I
received a readout from a meeting that
the president United States had with the
delegation on May 23rd in which the
briefing I received anyway indicated
that the president wanted the members of
that delegation which included in Bastyr
sunland to carry forth the policies that
were discussed in the course of that
meeting so that incurred and then
meeting in the Oval Office on May 23rd
is where you heard that information from
the readout or written readout from that
yes you testified that and I quote it
was clear that the members of that
inaugural delegate
were empowered by the president that's
what you testified you also said and I
quote as a practical matter it would be
ambassador Volcker and ambassador Soglin
presumably working with Taylor who would
be the ones really doing the continual
effort here did you understand that
ambassador Soglin had direct access to
the president I in the few occasions in
which I had conversations with
ambassador Sunland he often would let it
know that he was in direct contact with
the president that's all I knew
so you received that information
directly from ambassador Sandlin that he
had direct contact with the president in
previous occasions yes
not necessarily to this particular
matter so anything about ambassador
solomon's role that struck you as
problematic based on what I knew at the
time I was satisfied that this
delegation was what the president wanted
to have you know continued to pursue
these policies and I saw that ambassador
of Oakland it was professional had been
a foreign service officer and an
ambassador of distinction and steeped in
Ukrainian affairs was part of that group
so I had no great concerns so what you
knew at the time you were okay with his
role but did your opinion change about
his appropriateness of his role as I
testified I was not aware of these
various activities related to
negotiations over investigations
preconditions related to that I just
wasn't aware of it so I had no reason to
be making any kind of judgment one way
or the other have you reviewed the text
messages between ambassadors Sandlin and
bokor I've seen some of them that were
reported in the media
were you surprised by anything in those
messages that you heard report it or
personally witnessed or observed I was
surprised by what I saw in those reports
in the media I want to ensure I
understand your testimony ambassador
Hale you believed in Basra Solomon was
empowered by the president according to
what you found out from the May 23rd
meeting to work on Ukraine policy and
you
quote none of that really struck you as
problematic because of the time
differences there what you knew is that
correct
based on what I knew yes okay you are
the undersecretary for political affairs
you testified that in that capacity you
are responsible for the management of
the United States bilateral relations
with and I quote every country in the
world that we recognize for the
management of our policies towards those
countries as well as our relationship or
policies as they relate to multi lateral
organizations that include US policy and
relations with Ukraine it does but when
we have a special envoy who reports
directly to the secretary related to a
country or an issue that special envoy
will take the day-to-day
responsibilities how about US policy and
relations with the European Union yes I
am but you were not aware fully of
ambassador Salma's activities on behalf
of president Trump that's correct okay
thank you mister chair I yield back mr.
krishnamurthi good evening thank you so
much for being here
undersecretary Hale
you and your colleagues testified that
you've gathered official records at the
State Department with the understanding
that they would be provided to Congress
right I was not involved in the
decision-making or I have no
responsibilities related to gathering
documents I understood that it was under
way and I certainly received the
documents that I described earlier I see
in terms of the materials that were
collected do they include electronic
files and emails for instance I can only
speak to the documents that were made
available to me and it did include
emails and paper documents and paper
documents would tape recordings
potentially be among the files that are
gathered I really couldn't speculate on
that but you can't rule out that
possibility
I don't I don't know if tape recordings
but I so I can't really comment on that
and are you familiar with from whom the
documents have been collected like the
individual custodians I don't know that
sir you're aware that despite a duly
authorized congressional subpoena has
been served on the State Department we
have yet to receive even a single
document correct I understand that yes
miss Cooper in the interagency process
did anyone in any committee potentially
bring up the lack of allied funding as a
reason for why there should be a hold on
military assistance to Ukraine I can
only speak to the three meetings that I
attended that the PCC DSG and then PCC
and I have no recollection of the issue
of Allied burden-sharing coming up at
that point I did provide information in
my deposition about what I thought was a
completely separate query that I
received in mid-june from the Secretary
of Defense's front office and one of the
questions there just asked a question
about the degree to which allies were
contributing to Ukraine's security
assistance just to be very clear okay
but after the hold was put in place on
July 18th you did you haven't heard any
concerns about a lack of allied funding
as a reason for why the hole should be
in place in those meetings that I
attended I did not hear that or I do not
recall hearing that as a reason the only
reason that I heard was the president's
views on corruption no further
information got it same question to you
undersecretary Hill could you repeat the
question so I assume you didn't hear
about the lack of allied funding as a
reason for the whole booty being put in
place after July 18th no I never heard a
reason for the hold you never I assume
neither of you heard any reason
whatsoever for why the hold was in place
except for the fact that OMB put it in
place at the direction of the
president right that's that's correct
and I assume you know one of my
colleagues brought up the idea that the
hold was put in place to assess whether
or not President szalinski was legit I
assumed that was not a reason that was
offered either no sir I never heard that
as a reason I heard no reason Under
Secretary Hale what is the importance of
a world leader having a meeting at the
White House well really just
case-by-case but particularly for a new
leader it's an extremely important
opportunity to demonstrate the strength
of our relationship for building of that
relationship at a personal level
leadership level to demonstrate common
goals how about in the case of President
Solinsky how important was it for him to
have this a meeting at the White House
was President Trump well I never talked
to president Solinsky about that myself
I met him before he became president I
met with President poroshenko and the
two leading candidates but as a expert
on these matters is it fair to say that
a new world leaders such as President
Solinsky having a meeting at the White
House with President Trump is extremely
important for his image that he projects
especially toward folks like Russia well
an oval office meeting is incredibly
valuable for any foreign leader let me
just state that general principle and
for a Ukrainian president it is indeed
what you just said to demonstrate that
the bond between the United States and
Ukraine is strong and that there is
continuity in our policies and that we
are going to continue to work together
in our policy goals including countering
Iran a Russian aggression and
intimidation of Ukraine thank you so
much I yield back
that concludes the member questioning
mr. Nunez do you have any concluding
remarks thank the gentleman what have we
learned from Democrats impeachment
inquiry they promised the country a fair
hearing what have they delivered the
impeachment version of three-card Monte
notorious short con card trick where the
mark in this case President Trump
the American public stands no chance of
winning Democrats promised the
whistleblowers testimony in fact they
told us that we need to speak with the
whistleblower and then we learned that
the whistleblower coordinated with the
Democratic staff before alerting the
intelligence community's Inspector
General to hide their con that
immigrants pound the table and Gaslight
the country telling us that the
whistleblower is entitled to an
imaginary statutory right of anonymity
they accuse us of trying to out the
whistleblower knowing that there are the
only ones who know who he is
yeah Devin's a total clown so we're
gonna cut it because we've got to get
over to the studio and get set up there
will be an 8:30 so in 40 minutes there
will be a pre-debate stream on YouTube
and then at the top of the hour we'll go
over to twitch for the actual debate
livestream I hope you'll join me there
in